as the pandemic eases the world famous
dance company palobolis is returning to
the stage
last year when covet halted live
performances
the dance company turned its creative
energy to a unique program to help
people keep moving
nikki batiste shows us how they did it
[Music]
the modern dance troupe palabolos is
known for its ability to manipulate the
human form
connecting with each other to create
gravity-defying feats that look
fluid and nearly effortless
the company was founded in 1971 by
dartmouth college grads with very little
exposure to dance
palobolis has been dubbed the rebellious
dance company why is that
well i think part of it was from the
start with
not having any dance training they also
didn't like wearing clothes
so there was a lot of a lot of nudity oh
i'm so glad you guys are all here today
but deep in the woods of western
connecticut these rebels have found
another cause
same sequence look starting with just
the head
they're training seniors in a skill
critical to their choreography
the art of balance and then lift it up
emily kent is the group's education
director
plus really is about movement is for
everybody
this is a way that people
who maybe never thought they would be
dancing are
are dancing and moving their bodies in
ways that they never would have
we're gonna do uh the one where we
pretend like we're putting it down on
the ground and then up on the shelf so
they're exercising in a way to ensure
they can move
throughout their lives i just want you
to keep your eye on that letter we're
doing some things with our eyes
we're working on mobility of different
joints and cardiovascular or
strength of picking up something that's
heavy back and around
everything that she does for us
is helping us grow old
ellen and lou hide it patricia werner
and 4g
smith are some of kent's devoted class
members
that's the main reason we're here
is to live healthier as we age
how has palabolos changed you i have
more stamina for things
i don't have empty arms as much as i did
i feel like for years i was working too
much to do the right
amount of exercise and so i actually
feel better than i felt when i was
younger
you want to practice this motion as much
as possible they're also
boosting their ability to simply stay on
their own
two feet what have you learned about the
importance of balance
in your life as you've gotten less young
it's extremely important even as a
firefighter
we went to calls where people have
fallen down the stairs all the people
and i still struggle with it but if i'm
going to like
fall you can regain yourself after these
classes
find your position stay kent used her
time in quarantine to expand the class's
reach
zooming with folks across the country
right hand up and over
and developing a video series there is a
small fee for the classes
watch it as it goes up in person classes
also continued through much of the
pandemic
give your neighbor a high five it was a
physical and mental lifeline for
participants
this was our social life especially
during covert my god
the value of the covid
pod we formed i think it was a really
important part of our feeling connected
to
life let's do a little toss and catch
this really is that like power of
connection
to art and movement and to each other as
human beings
good try the same thing for cbs this
morning nikki batiste new preston
connecticut
okay guys yeah finally a workout i can
do yeah
i like anything that makes you feel
younger as you're getting older
like yoga-ish